[Music]
hi I'm dr. Thomas West Hillsdale College
teaching the politics department I'm a
professor of politics and my talk today
is going to be on natural rights in the
American Revolution and the topic is a
good one because it indicates two things
one is a theory a theoretical concept
natural rights and the other is a
historical event rooted in a time and
place the American Revolution so in
order to understand our founding it's
important I think to grasp the
connection between theory and practice
between the ideas that motivated or that
helped the founders to structure their
activities and actions against Britain
at the same time to understand what the
practical fight was all about with the
British that led to American
independence in the period leading up to
the revolution and independence in 1776
people in the colonies had been pretty
much left alone by the British with some
exceptions there was a long period in
which there was a kind of uneasy truce
you might say between the colonial
legislature is elected by the colonists
and the royal governor sent over from
the king and from Britain and there was
there was a rivalry there the colonial
legislatures tended to get their way
much to the chagrin often of the British
officials but and that was an
arrangement that lasted for quite a
while but then there was the French and
Indian War which changed everything that
war concluded in 1763 with Treaty of
peace that then led both sides both the
British and the Americans to think very
differently about their relationship
with each other from the British side
they became increasingly impatient with
the colonists now that there was no
longer the French threat on the northern
border to worry about they needed the
colonists to fight the French which had
been a theme throughout the 18th century
but now
French were defeated they're gone as a
serious power in North America and it's
up to venit became the British the
British Empire but that meant that they
didn't the British government didn't
have to treat the colonists so politely
and they also pointed out you the
colonists we've been defending you all
this time and you haven't been paying
taxes or at least not very many taxes so
we're going to do something about that
I'm going to start taxing you and we're
also gonna start making it clear to you
that you're part of the Empire and you
have to obey us on the colonial side of
course Americans attitude was now that
the French threat is gone we don't need
the British as much so all that time
when the British were saying you know
you need us and I didn't need the
colonists didn't need the British forces
to with respect to the French now it was
what's let's go off on her own and least
or at least let's not be pressed and
pushed around by the British there was
not an immediate desire for independence
in 1763 but the attitude of the
Americans was let's not let the British
push us around anymore let's stick to
our own way of doing things and stand
make the British acknowledge that that
led to the crisis that started in the
1760s 70s leading up to the actual
declaration of independence in 1776 what
the colonists were doing throughout this
period is not just reacting in a
visceral way to their desire to be free
but they also had at their pant at hand
ready at hand a doctrine of natural
rights and natural law which had been
around the colonies for quite a while
these ideas had come into the colonies
sometime around 1710 or shortly
thereafter became widely known and
discussed in the colonies throughout
that period between 1710 and the end of
the French and Indian War 50 years later
and the Americans therefore were able to
say look it's not just a matter of our
not deserve our wish to not be dominated
by you people you British it's also we
have a right to be free we have a right
to self-government
and the British of course in response
said no you don't you're part of the
Empire you have to obey the Parliament
and that's the store that's the end of
it we might compromise me I'd let you
have a little freedom but that was the
gist of what happened so what the appeal
to the natural rights doctrine which
began in earnest in the 1760s was was an
appeal to a doctrine that is claim that
claims to be universally true for all
human beings everywhere and that's what
gave the revolution its peculiar flavor
of not just being a local quarrel
between this and that group but a
quarrel that was made in the name of the
universal principles of natural law and
natural rights of something that is true
now and forever and will always be true
about human relationships that teaching
of the of the natural law is stated all
over the place in founding era documents
you could find in the Declaration of
Independence most famously you see it in
state after state each gate states that
put together constitutions most of them
had Bills of Rights had statements of
principle these doctrines were widely
held you hear occasionally some people
will say well that was just Jefferson's
idea and he was influenced by the French
that's ridiculous that these ideas had
been around the colonies for 60 years by
that time and widely accepted and known
and became officially part of the record
in that in the revolution and what you
find in these state constitutions is
various restatements of the same ideas
that are in the Declaration of
Independence and they help to clarify so
in the Declaration you have all men are
created equal and that has led lots of
people to make all kinds of assumptions
about men and women about blacks and
whites about and so on it's about it's
not about human equality in the sense of
we're all the same it's about human
equality in the sense of no one has the
right to dominate anybody else without
their consent the founders had a way of
they different formulations of this
for example Virginia all men are by
nature equally free and independent or
Massachusetts all men are born free and
equal these were different versions of
the same thought that no one has the
right to rule another that there is a
and then that was also put in moral
language in terms of Rights and natural
law so the right the natural right idea
arises from the notion that not only are
we born equal in the sense nobody's
ruling we also have a right a moral
claim that we can make on behalf of that
state of we do bar we do deserve to be
equal in free and equally free and from
that then comes the idea of a natural
right to Liberty from which in the
founders minds all the other rights in
it in one way or another can be derived
once you're if you have a right to be
free not to be ruled by another means
that means a right not to be assaulted
not to be killed by another that's the
right to life if you have the right to
be free to use your own mind and your
own body to acquire property that means
you have a right to quiet to property if
you have a right not to be dominated in
the way you worship God that's a
religious freedom right the basic idea
is all men are born free in the sense
that everybody who is part of a
government ought to have given that
person is here her consent to be part of
that government equality then can be
understood to be a moral claim in two
ways one is it's about the moral rights
and obligations of human beings to each
other and as I said just now their basic
right right to Liberty and all the other
rights that follow from it and the other
is a claim about the rights rule who has
the right to rule born equally free and
independent means not born into a slave
relationship or subordinate relationship
understand of course when they talked
about this they didn't mean children
they always understood children are
under the temporary control or wardship
of their parents but that was always
understood to be a warship that was a
preparation for freedom once the
children grow up there was no idea of
patriarchy throughout life in the
founders conception once you've reached
the age of majority let's say 21
typically in American law at that time
you're free free of your parents and
from then on you are free you are free
of everything unless it's the laws that
you've given your consent to obey and
it's that consent
it's that giving of consent collectively
that is what creates a nation creates a
people that is then to be governed by a
particular form of government founders
use the term social compact to mean the
agreement we all make with each other
fellow citizens make with each other to
form a government and to accept the
rules made by that government and once
you're in the social compact you then
become an exclusive body apart from the
rest of humanity and they the government
you're creating is for you you your
fellow citizens and protection of you
and your rights it's only for the prytt
not for the protection of the rest of
mankind and their rights so what does it
mean to be free and equal in a daily
day-to-day situation I like to use the
example of a job when you apply for a
job you are saying to the employer
I have something valuable to offer you
my labor and if you offer me something
valuable let's say pay a salary we'll
make an agreement and the agreement is
an agreement between equals I agree to
be ruled by you insofar as I'm employed
by you you agree to pay me and it's a
relationship of subordination it's not a
relationship with permanent
subordination that would be slavery
it's an employment contract always has
limits beyond which the employer is not
allowed to go in order to protect the
life liberty and property of the
employee but that's one example a simple
example of how equality works in
practical life and day to day life now
the idea of consent of the governed is
fundamental to the founding and in fact
the Revolution itself was primarily
fought in the name of consent because it
was the the issue was can
British imposed taxes upon our people
without the consent of our own locally
elected legislative bodies the answer
was no they can't and that has to be at
contacts as in any form of government
intrusion on our life liberty or
property has to be with the agreement of
the people who live under that
government and that has to be expressed
through elected legislatures or through
democracy where people get together in
person as saying in New York New England
Township
now that consent what did that actually
mean in practice in terms of structure
and government do we want to have a
legislative body is it a good idea to
have an executive what about judging
what about courts all of that had to be
worked out and thrashed out and that was
an area where a lot of the disagreements
in the founding came forward it was a
general agreement on consent in the form
of elections general agreement that
government needed to have some kind of
an executive for prosecutions for
directing the Armed Forces for dealing
with sudden problems like an uprising
you know organizing the militia but
basically there was agreement the
disagreements in terms of structure of
government I'm not going to go into
today that's going to be the topic of
the next couple of talks in this series
what I'm going to focus on today is the
subject of what government is supposed
to do
once it's conformed the Declaration of
Independence has a nice formulation to
secure these rights governments are
instituted among men to secure these
rights what does that mean what does
security of Rights mean you can also
look at the state constitutions and say
how did they describe the purpose of
government was it the same was it
security of Rights and the answer is
well they used sometimes they often they
use different language one of the terms
that was often used as the to explain
the purpose of government is the word
protection protection is what the
government is supposed to do
meaning protection against harm to your
own life liberty and property and that
protection is to vest two sides it's the
side of the national government against
against the outsiders potential foreign
attack and protection against your
fellow citizens who might harm you in
the in arm your life labor to your
property because of their because
they're misbehaving so protection
there's a let me just give you an
example from the Virginia Declaration of
Rights government ought to be instituted
for the common benefit protection and
security of the people nation or
community so that's what to secure these
rights means protection benefit of
protection and security of the peak of
the people nation or community again the
emphasis is not on is on it's on our
people the government is not protecting
people in Mexico or Canada or elsewhere
in the world that's a subject that is
often misunderstood today there's an
assumption today that if there's human
rights are universal it's the job of
every government in the world to protect
got rights all over the world the
founders rejected that idea completely
and totally another example from the New
Jersey Constitution preamble the King of
Great Britain has refused protection to
the good people of these colonies
therefore we have a right to revolution
refused protection that was the one word
you're not protecting us against injury
and in fact as New Jersey went on to say
is you're attacking us you're harming us
you're harming our people you're putting
soldiers here and shooting at us so then
the question becomes alright what
policies the government have to adopt in
order to do this protecting of the
people so the OP first point of course
is protecting the fur outs ejectment
projection against outsiders my means of
armed forces by means of what we call
foreign policy diplomacy statecraft
negotiation perhaps making alliances but
in the end it comes down to do you have
sold
in the field who can physically defeat a
potential or an actual threat to the
life liberty and property of American
citizens so this first part of
governments protection protection or
protective duty is about armed forces
and that of course does include border
enforcement one of the points of having
a nation of your own is it's for the
people who live here anyone who wants to
come here has to ask permission and
permission is not automatic it's given
again by consent of the governed by the
consent of the people who live here the
idea of a universal right to immigrate
to a nation that says I don't want you
here
founders would have said no that's
that's immoral that's a violation of the
moral principle that all men are created
equal and that we therefore who have
created our own government have a moral
right to say who will be our future
fellow citizens that's our duty and our
right not someone elses the second part
of protection and what government has to
do to protect is is to create laws
against crimes that's the most urgent
part of the of the domestic politics
side of the founders argument and so one
of the topics that came up early on in
America in during the Revolution and in
its aftermath was to create
constitutions and laws to protect
citizens criminal laws for example
Jefferson had a great quote on that in
his he put together a proposed revision
of the laws of the state of Virginia in
1778 in which he states that it's
precisely because vicious and immoral
men who try to take away the rights of
other people that we have criminal law
and without criminal law he said the
purpose of society would not be achieved
by which he meant protection and
security of life liberty and property so
if you ask people today sometimes I'll
ask my students how does the government
secure our rights
they'll often give you a statement like
well that's what the Supreme Court is
for and they have rules against
discrimination and so on well the
founders would say no government
protects your rights not just through
the judiciary but through all three
branches of government you have to have
a legislature to make laws you have to
have an executive to carry out arrests
and prosecutions and punishments and a
judiciary to decide is this person who's
accused by the government
truly guilty or not guilty you need all
three branches that's what makes
government protection possible through
criminal law and and that's what we see
you know occasionally their TV shows
based on this idea of you know trials
people prosecute that's how it's
supposed to work one of the
characteristic features of government
today in America is the D prioritization
of criminal law enforcement not
everywhere but especially in major
cities of America today the ability of
police and prosecutors to to find
criminals prosecute them successfully
and have them punished is minimal there
are some cities in which the police if
they're called out on a theft if you
call the police inside somebody stole
something out of my house they'll go
okay well fill out a report for you you
can take it to the insurance company but
no we're not gonna look into it
founding fathers would say you guys
don't get what government is for it's
for protection and protection means you
have to deter crime by making it clear
to people who commit crimes they're
gonna pay a penalty so you know figure
out why you know what what's wrong what
happened why why do our priorities
somehow go somewhere else and if you ask
Police Department's today or prosecuting
RIT they'll say well we don't have a
budget for it
which means something has gone wrong at
the level of the state legislature or at
the level of city government that we're
got money is being spent on something
less than there's a lower priority
than actual protection of the lives and
properties of citizens that's a problem
from the point of view of the founders
but it is the way we do government today
one could sum up the founders conception
of law enforcement that was developed
during the revolution in in to fray in
two phrases equal protection of the laws
and due process of law equal protection
meaning and the founders view equal
protection meant when there's there's
going to be a rule a general rule that
applies to everybody it will define what
crimes are and will say what the
penalties are going to be and
government's duty is to provide equal
protection so no matter how wealthy the
perpetrator might be what race he might
be or the sex of the person committing
the crime government has the same
obligation to prosecute and punish in
the same way anyone who does that who
commits the crime that's a that's
fundamental but precisely because
government is so strong and powerful
when it's engaging in this activity of
protecting it also needs to follow
procedures called due process of law
meaning you don't just take somebody and
punish them without giving them a chance
to defend themselves so government has
to prove its case in theory at least in
court for any significant punishment to
take place for person to be deprived of
liberty or property or money trial a
right to defend the right to call
witnesses a right to speak to about to a
cross examine to deal with whatever you
need to do bring forward whatever you
need to bring forward in order to show
if you can I didn't do that I wasn't I'm
not guilty
those two concepts equal protection of
the law and due process of law
were later embodied in Fourteenth
Amendment which was meant to take the
basic founders political theory of what
government supposed to do that was
developed during the American Revolution
and then apply it to the States each
state was from then on obliged by the
federal cost
tuition to provide the same protection
of the laws and of the new process of
law that that was already required and
expected at the federal level in its own
law enforcement jurisdiction one of the
early debates in America was over do we
need a federal government and if so what
should be its scope and its powers the
founders came up with a very simple way
of dividing up that labor the federal
government was going to be primarily
responsible for foreign policy the state
governments for domestic policy with
some exceptions but basically the
federal government didn't really have a
whole lot to do in early American
history other than foreign policy now
there were some exceptions to that the
state's government federal government
was given some powers to regulate
commerce to basically to maintain a
national free market and so on but that
those were general exceptions generally
the states handled things having to do
with property law commerce and contracts
things of that kind and I'll be talking
about that and a talk I give later on in
the series today when we teach American
government in college we often tend to
focus on the national government that's
of course the exciting part the big you
know the one that everyone notices and
of course today the feds have become so
important we tend to forget the role of
the states which still remains quite
powerful even today I believe I believe
the percentage of court cases that are
handled at the federal and versus the
state level is about that's over ninety
percent still our state court cases so
most law most law enforcement most legal
issues come up not at the federal level
at all and that is how they designed it
and to that extent it still there's to
some extent that same division of labor
still prevails
one of the things that John Quincy Adams
pointed out in a famous speech he gave
on July fourth eighteen eighteen twenty
one was that they you know that the
Revolution the American Revolution had
its heroes and of course what everyone
tends to think of things like George
Washington the others great generals of
that period the the soldiers the people
who sacrifice their lives to create an
independent nation and that's truth Adam
says that was true but what he adds to
that is he says you know there are other
people who were also heroes of the
American Revolution and we don't tend to
acknowledge that those are the people he
said who figured out how to write the
constitutions and the laws state and
federal that have given us our Liberty
and enable us to sustain that Liberty
they said they're heroes too because
that's not easy to do I want to conclude
this talk by asking the question what
then was America meant to be its time of
the founding and I want to emphasize
again ideas are not people the ideas of
the American Revolution were indeed
unique to the American Revolution but
those ideas are meant to be universal
for all mankind but it was a particular
people it was these people over in
America the British settlers other
Europeans were here predominantly
Europeans who made the nation what it
was and they were not randomly assembled
from all around the world one of the
things the founders were very conscious
of is how difficult it is to establish
and sustain a political regime there's a
it's going to be a free regime a free a
freedom regime of freedom John J in
Federalist to points out that a that
Americans really do belong together
not just because they held the same
political principles and he does mention
that but also because they are quote a
people descended from the same ancestors
speaking the same language professing
the same religion attached to the same
principles of government very similar
in their manners and customs and Jays
point partly was if it hadn't been for
all those things we already had in
common prior to forming the Union we
might not have been able to do it
liberty is only possible to be
established in the founders minds if the
people are capable of supporting Liberty
and living according to the requirements
of Liberty
there are many cultures in the world
today and there were then to where the
people who live in these places don't
like freedom and to have no experience
of freedom the founders in fact doubted
openly whether places like Latin America
or even some places in Europe could ever
maintain a regime of political freedom
natural rights belong to everyone in the
founders view but it you have the right
obviously the right to create a free
country but you don't always have the
ability to it depends on who lives there
and what their attitudes are and how
good their leadership is in some cases
the founders pointed out you can't have
consent of the governed if you're going
to have any kind of protection of the
rights of the individual there was a
revolution in Haiti that took place
during the 1790s and people the founding
was saying they're not going to be able
to have a free government there they're
not gonna have election you can't have
an elective government in Haiti probably
a military despotisms the best they're
going to do that was the quote from
Hamilton and Jefferson held the same
view when in get asked about Latin
America in the eighteen 1820s he said
look this is place it's gonna be really
difficult to form any kind of solid
lasting free government there I hope
they can do it he said they ought to
they deserve it but it's going to be
tough the founders had answers as to how
to keep the population morally capable
of being free they didn't think it would
work everywhere but they did think it
would work here
I'll talk about that later in the series
thank you
you